classic not only online classic actually
between magnus and westchester in the
semi-finals that would be a very
exciting match
so c4 played by itoyzaga
and magnus may be struggling to find the
game
yeah very impressive game we are one-way
traffic yeah you have the feeling that
uh
uh it's always like that yeah you feel
that
uh it was a guy is a complete amateur
and uh but
not that i mean it's the impression it
makes but
uh we are very
very far from uh the the reality it is a
guy is just a very strong
gunmaster 2650 on 2650 and even better
in blitz he's
really good in blitz but i mean this
time he was crushed
in this whole solimo he didn't get
really out of the opening
so i don't know i don't know what do you
think are some chances of winning the
world cup
i really don't know i don't know if i
will bother him with such
questions today
it's hard to say because it's not easy
it's not easy so but he's a favorite but
you have seven seven matches to win
so it's a lot of
it's a lot of troubles on the way
i mean last time it was too boo in the
third round that was very early
uh but that's a great challenge that's
why
he's uh he's trying
why magnus wait a lot magnus doesn't
wait
magnus doesn't wait magnus just probably
doesn't find the game
and yes very good point frederico if
magnus
lost to switzerland in euro
soccer it means that magnus might lose
it's possible actually it's possible
that magnus might lose a match
in world cup that's everything is
possible after that
really
anything can happen in sport that's what
it means
okay so let's see
we'll see on the camera so magnus is
trying to find the game it's totally
easy of course and he played
okay c4 knight f6 g3 c6
so it is a guy i think it is main
alberto so it will be well prepared
hola b5 this is
just out of book to put him
out of book oh this is not
it shouldn't be good um
but it taking some space after all white
only played like c4 bishop g2 so when
white plays like that
it's always possible to do some b5 some
early b5
and it's not easy to take advantage of
this
a4 b4
and a5 um
castle now you will try to to has
this pawn on b4 so maybe first
the knight on b3 maybe bishop p3 or c1
um and um yeah knight c6 makes a lot of
sense
bishop a6 is normal just to protect
because
if you go to b7 there's always a6 which
is very unpleasant
a6 at least you can go here sometimes
you can pin even if the hook
let's say some scenario like that you
should be five
c1 here you have some bishop a4
sometimes okay so pawn was
hanging as well but just to show the
idea
so now but it's always a guy has to play
faster
because he played bishop p3 in any case
i understand it's i was one of the
victim
uh of magnus so i know it's
always very impressive to play against
magnus and playing well he's playing
fast and it's a nightmare but if you
start playing
slow as well then it becomes uh
just impossible impossible task
so queen d2 okay that makes a lot of
sense to me
and he played is
reasonably fast so this gives e5 d4
maybe
but
e5 okay this weakens a bit the
light square let's say if you play d4
we'll just go bishop g5 i will take here
and you see this bishop suddenly has an
open diagonal so you can even remove the
queen knight fd2 knight c4 you have some
squares
give some square it's a beautiful center
but you have to be careful
okay so uh what to do with black i don't
like d4
he's thinking it's not an easy position
maybe rook c6 as well as india who takes
c6 just giving the exchange knight e5
then you have nice controls this pawn on
a7 he's always hanging
so this is very interesting as well
i don't know e5 in a bliss game then
it's difficult to control
so he played d4 bishop g5 e4 it was
it was these calculations okay
yeah that's the difference between uh
our champion and myself i didn't see e4
at all
and that was he was considering that
it's clear
uh since the start after bishop
obviously has 92 now
and bishop did knight b3 bad news
this is a fork so he's taking first on
f6
which makes a lot of sense if you take
on f3 internet so i just take here
and take the pawn and it's it's finished
and e3
wow magnus carlsen
this is this is magnus carlsen okay this
is interesting
if bishop is seven takes takes
takes takes here oh this is not so clear
actually
exchange up for white but not so clear
and if it takes here you just i guess
you want to take
take bishop f6 and you have some
compensation because rookie 8 because
upon b2
because the dark square or the king
so this is very interesting concept and
he played it at tempo so he saw it
actually when he was
calculating e5 you already saw that
position here
this is completely clear that here he
was already
considering this pawn sacrifice
so what did eduardo
so it seems that magnus is in great
shape
queen d2 okay this is beautiful
compensations
for the pawn okay only this this bishop
on a6 is really misplaced
but you can't have it all
otherwise you are winning maybe bishop
b5 to replace it to
now protect this knight on c6 with the
bits
hanging
king h1 and h5 alpha zeresque
move h5 h4
against the king okay first we have to
take care of that one
i guess bishop b5 what else i don't see
any other
squares okay bishop b5 played
one minute for each player position is
very unclear
but i would take black
to be honest it's much easier to play
okay b1 that looks like a bad move
okay it's protecting here it's obvious
this idea but okay he's giving back a
pawn
um which uh the engine didn't like
because of 94
well played to take knight d6 setting
knight take f6
and if
um bishop p7
queen f4 and some attack ah so it's not
so clear
wow he played he's playing style in that
game he took takes
and now what what does he want
it's beautiful it's a beautiful extra
sacrifice but
uh it costs an exchange
so i mean it's not of course the bishop
is
on the way ah he wants to play some end
game really oh
queen d5 this is a good move eduardo
playing really fast
and creating troubles for the world
champion
he taking a pawn i would have gone for
the end game hundred times
okay that's weird to me they end game
and e5 and you open up the lines for
your hooks this is tricky this is
definitely too tricky bishop d3 here
it's a good move apparently
okay you can take as well and ah no ah
the knight is
97 then you can take i think it's just
good for
wait queen d5 yeah he wants the end game
finally
if bishop d3 there is rock d1 this point
is not hanging knight d6 is a good
blockade now b3
i guess b3 is very reasonable you just
want to to freeze this hook
without losing the b2 pawn b3 is played
bishop c3 and now you have to
maybe find something like that it's not
easy because the hook doesn't have too
many squares
uh rook c1 or d1 i don't know c1 is okay
a5 but how do you improve your position
knight h3
that's a long way and knight f2 he wants
knight f4 okay bishop b5 bishop f1 it's
times crumble 20
eight seconds for itoi zagat 12 seconds
for magnus carlsen
king g7 but now it's winning objectively
speaking it's winning for white
because it's it's an exchange and uh
there's no pawns
and now roxy fire will come when the
bishop will move forward c5
is ah or c7 first okay seven he wants
okay that will be one one is my guess
takes
b3 okay now we have to take care of that
guy but it's not such a big deal because
the bishop is controlling the
square on b1
yeah okay six he is attacking the knight
and he wants rook b6
but bishop a4 so a5 first and then on b6
i would probably get tricked in that
in that in that position let's see
eduardo
12 seconds knight g1 playing with fire
king d5 knight f3
some panic for eduardo it's not easy
it's not easy
b2 hook b6 now
tattooing is a pawn and he wants to push
he will play will b8
no i don't know what he will play b3 is
good
bishop b5
bishop b1 bishop a5 he lost all response
oh come on
we want of course i mean like i'm
obviously voting for magnus but i want
some kind of excitement you know i don't
want this to be five zero and uh
and go to bed yeah we don't go to bed
anyway there is uh
there is wesley against
lee kuank he was winning he missed it
it's a
it's a pity for eduardo obviously oh for
now bishop before was
threatening i think he's going to lose
that one
just ah no it's not good to give a check
of course it's very tempting because you
give a check you play one move but
uh this is just the king is getting
closer to the
to the punking a3 seems hacking s3 is
still okay seven
i played bishop d4 okay [ __ ] a3 this
is game over
king a2 before he will play it will be
knocking b3 now this is over g4 and you
get
um you can do anything
that was that was close